10 words every screenwriter should know
and utilize in their script
feature-length script 10 words they
should know and utilize in the screen in
their script right moving from let's say
great or something simple to something
more like arduous stodgy Byzantine like
are there certain words I mean this is
just like this sort of strange throwaway
question but sometimes it's important
because it gets people out of the just
the things that they should put words
they should put into their screenplay
yeah something favorite flavorful words
yeah I don't know that I'm gonna be able
to do I'm always terrible at you know my
at top 10 lists i will i will say come
from a background where where I try not
to use the versions of to be and these
kind of like jaron words like if you
know she is walking you know she walks
to the door you're like what's the
difference but you're kind of looking
for the more visceral words so and and
you are looking for you're looking for
the verbs that that kind of let you not
have to use adverbs so you know you try
and constantly trying to stay away from
those kind of Hawaii adverbs so you know
you don't say she she you could you
could say she she starts walking to the
door confidently or you could say she
struts to the door so you're looking for
those robust kind of muscular words do I
have a list of those words i don't know
that i do but i know that i'm always
searching for them do you yes are you
coming from journalism you know and
that's lovely that it's it's it's an
interesting question that I strangely
can't answer because there's so many
beautiful words that one could use
and and when I think you know and I
can't even think about one from even our
script that I was just like that was the
most marvelous word ever um I think that
a lot of what Barrington has said just
just finding ways to utilize the
language that is bright and full and
even complex are great things to do but
again one particular word or a series of
words because they are always dependent
on what you're writing about because I
you know I love the word lied but I
don't ever see that and I don't think
that's in our sky that would never be in
our script because that doesn't describe
anyone in our script but I it's a word
that I particularly love because it says
so much and it's such a little word or
petite word so yeah yeah that's that's a
hard one I usually can answer anything
yeah that's a stumper I think about
verbs a lot and and maybe because of the
medium I think I try to think about
light I mean it's a it's a
two-dimensional medium and you can't
really smell things and and the dialogue
is there so you can kind of you know we
do this thing where we cap the the
sounds you know the car screeches around
the corner to like kind of give you that
that sense but I think also
understanding that there's you know
glistens is you know and glows and yeah
like the light is what you know kind of
watery or you know trying to to get to
transmit the texture of things the sheen
of things is is interesting probably not
always applicable depending on your
subject matter but
um yeah I used my thesaurus a lot so
it's it's my favorite book
you